well hello reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and John Humphrey over here I am
readying an all comic book format
material with my clothing to watch the
trailer for Paul Thomas Anderson oh make
sure it's Thomas not WS this might be
Daniel day-lewis his last movie
apparently he's going out yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
beautiful
Hobbs has made my dreams come true and
I've given him what he desires master
returned
[Music]
[Music]
arrival has cast a very long shadow my
brother can stop playing this game what
game what precisely is the nature of my
game sent here to ruin my evening and
possibly my entire life
[Music]
[Music]
he's going out with a big bang oh yeah
yeah that's the vibe idea this looks
like a PT Anderson picture a tale of you
know a guy very dedicated almost
obsessed with something almost obsessed
clearly yes that's Paul Thomas Anderson
style obsession loving but in kind of a
greedy aspect yeah they're always like
twisted Early's lately they're always
kind of twisted character study yeah
seems to have those qualities of like
you'd probably just gonna appear in on
this situation for a long time yeah
watch these people's lives for a bit and
then the movies just sort of gonna stop
he's really good at a capturing
lifestyle of killer bears it feels like
an authentic British film about a royal
family I wouldn't have guessed this was
a PT Anderson film off the trailer this
was you know like oh this is a film from
the UK coming out you know yeah well in
the period and the production values in
just the style is you know is it kind of
a departure from the the settings I'm
used to seeing him and half okay that's
cool you know it's a bit more of a
sophisticated world the master and you
know inherent vice and stuff like that
those are a bit more gruff and I get the
sense that this is gonna be a more
subtly unsettling movie because his
movies are always sort of unsettling
when you peer in on these lifestyles
well yeah well it looks like Daniel
day-lewis and Vicky cribes we're gonna
get an introduction into the lifestyle
of Daniel day-lewis as character this
fashion designer with the kind of this
dark obsession I don't know what the
secrets are that he's hiding inside of
the clothes he's designing I thought I
was gonna go down some type of criminal
secret thing but it doesn't look like
it's going down at all I feel like it's
gonna strictly focus on his relationship
and his obsession and control that
Daniel day-lewis is so good at in
happening I like when he plays
characters who have issues with power
and control then it's gonna deteriorate
their relationship and it's gonna be
very subtle undertones it's gonna be a
lot of coming from within dan day-lewis
retiring I kind of would want him to go
out with something a little bit more on
the theatrical dramatic side something
bigger yeah it's Danny Lewis so I go out
where that powerhouse type of
performance I wonder from his
perspective I'm like you know every role
seems like he just becomes a new person
through
I've got to imagine that maybe in his
own way this is that for him movies kind
of always have this spiral you know that
seems like it would be hard for
especially a method actor to really
immerse in but yeah I get what you mean
this is a little more of like a
oh it's subtle drama I guess you know
drama were the most gritty stuff is in
the the little details you know I gotta
be honest as much as that like PC
Anderson mm-hmm I'm not too drawn to the
spell well I've had back and forth with
his movies lately like I liked inherent
vice a lot but the master was something
that I had difficulty with connecting to
enjoying as a movie going experience and
there will be blood I'm sorry everybody
I get why it's great and that movie just
leaves me cold I'm watching this trailer
and I'm like I'm intrigued in this
trailer format but knowing his movies
I'm a little bit like I like the worlds
I like spending time in the worlds
always the same time that I'm kind of
getting the impression this is not the
kind of movie that you could really put
in a trailer format I really feel like
many of PGA Tour's now these of late are
there's so much about the sinking into
the scenes that are going on he like
salutely really let his actors explore
and it seems like it's really gonna
hinge on the performances of Daniel
day-lewis and Vicky crepes create
ascribes with these kind of scenes that
are going on I imagine that these things
will probably a lot more gripping into
when I'm watching the actual movie
because it's gonna be so subtle in terms
of its undertones that I don't imagine
you could really make it a super
intriguing trailer that has this
dramatic weight to it yes opposed to
that looks interesting you kind of just
got to make a tone pastiche for a movie
like this because like most every scene
in a Paula Thomas Anderson movie is
gonna be much longer than anyway you
know it's not like he crams his movies
with moments it's all about the
long-term and yeah I do kind of agree
that I guess the pedigree is more
exciting than the actual yeah this
trailer and especially for Daniel
day-lewis his last film like okay what's
gonna make this special what's gonna
make this the stamp or is it just the
last movie he wanted to do and there we
go alright guys well do you have your
pulse raised for phantom thread is PT
Anderson the greatest director you've
ever known
Daniel day-lewis the most underrated
actor of all time nobody gives that guy
any craves no cred somebody's no correct
tired of him being overshadowed in
performances it's sad really you can
subscribe to the realistic rejects and
check us out on social media links in
the description box yeah yeah